[Music]
foreign
Captain Torrance flight Commander how
can I help you fugitive extradition
[Music]
oh is he dangerous what did he do
homicide 15 years ago I don't want to
scare the rest of the passengers I'm
afraid you're stuck with this Captain
get him on board let's have a good
flight
I'm cutting right through the top of the
storm
that's to keep everybody in their seats
no exceptions all right
foreign
[Music]
the Jolo Island cluster
it's run by separatists and militias the
Filipino Army won't even go there
anymore
the clock is ticking every minute
matters
foreign we can count those minutes in
lives lost or saved
an emergency I'm captain Brody Torrance
I like this guy
Maxwell Carver England country
[Music]
my passengers my responsibility
need your help
you're gonna need this
form of militarism you can see that
why did they lock you up no one cares
what really happened but they say
redemption can be found in the most
unusual places
if you do this you'll probably never see
your family again
I have a daughter and it had every
intention of making a home
we are going to come at us with
everything they've got
we're getting off this island
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
your days of fighting for the so-called
greater good
are over
this is our chance
control the truth
the concepts of right and wrong for
everyone for centuries to come
you're fighting to save an ideal that
doesn't exist
never did
you need to pick a sign
oh foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
living out my wildest dreams
Bianca
Rocky my dad
this is built on their shoulders
hey my man can I help you let me get all
the ground no I ain't sounding an
autographs but you get off my car you
don't remember me huh
[Music]
Damien
how long were you locked up 18 Years bro
just got out last week
I know I've been away a long time but I
got myself in shape I still got gas in
the tank come by the gym
thank you
[Music]
guys what happened with you too I didn't
tell you he was like brothers
I was the best though but I never got a
chance to prove that that's cute
I know what you doing Donnie you don't
owe this dude nothing
Damien's fighting the world he's trying
to hurt people I bounce for you you
think you mad try spending half your
life in a cell
why did somebody else live your life
I'm coming for everything you
threatening me
something that's going on with you
[Music]
now we passed talking then maybe you
just have to find out
I recognize mine I know that they needed
me yet
I need you to make all your fear
they're called a guilt
let go of whatever was and walk into
what is I feel those chains
[Music]
yes
[Music]
only the most broken people
[Music]
the feather serpent God
killing him
he will risk Eternal War
he's coming
[Music]
we know what you whisper
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
have you given any thought to where this
ends
the table will never stop
now this
no one
not even you
kill everyone
[Music]
you ready John
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Deer Creek International Business
Solutions how can I help you I am ready
well that's great ladybug ladybug your
new operational name oh I see what
you're doing ladybug's supposed to be
lucky
you don't have bad luck really
my bad luck is biblical I'm not even
trying to kill people when someone dies
I remember the suicidal belt boy you
drove him to the hospital hang in there
buddy and he didn't die okay the wedding
Johannesburg it's time for some change
do you want it simple for your first job
back doesn't get simpler
we need to find a person who took that
case
it's too easy [ __ ] what remember those
two wackos from oblivious job the twins
yeah and I'll show you their twins get
off the train
no
just stab me
nurse.com
I missed my stop something else going on
here hi you don't remember me you look
like every white homeless man I've ever
seen really you don't remember me
my dicks lady I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
I'm working on it get off at the next
stop it's so sweet easy when you say it
one little pricker I'm missing you know
what happens yes your blood congeals I
said yes
[ __ ] balls you're going to want to hear
the whole story between force and Kyoto
the white death with his army of
Assassins there's this solar psychotic
leader with the largest criminal
organization on the planet shoved right
inside
I don't see the way desert in any other
softest training we need to come up with
a plan
what's happening to your face maybe
there was a little head trauma Maybe all
right
I Gotta Get Off This Train
sorry buddy
exclusively in movie theaters
[Music]
I used to ask myself a lot of questions
Scott you're at ex-con how are you an
Avenger that doesn't make sense
but everywhere I go people tell me the
same thing thank you Spiderman
people still need help Dad that's why we
made this
like a satellite for deep space but
Quanah wait wait a minute you're sending
a signal down to the quantum Realm
turn it off
now
[Music]
where
Army
[Music]
it's a secret Universe beneath ours
he's so afraid of
it there's something I never told you
[Music]
thank you
it isn't what you think
[Music]
[Music]
I can get you home
and give you more time
[Music]
help me
so
What's it gonna be
Ant-Man
[Music]
why do you want to hunt
because you all think that I can't
I saw a sign in the sky
I'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
there's something out there I'm coming
with you
can't I'm trying to protect you protect
me from what
it's time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right
it knows how to hunt
I know how to survive
[Applause]
whatever did this I can kill you
foreign
here's the thing we're a team of Thieves
then when you do this
you're bound to make enemies
sometimes those enemies come looking for
Revenge
truth be told
we helped the wrong person steal the
wrong thing
I didn't mean to unleash the greatest
evil the world has ever known
but we're gonna fix it so how do we pull
that off
uh figure it out over a drink probably
best you need to give us a fighting
chance we're gonna need strength you got
this right I know you don't
we also need courage
[Music]
and you
what is that again it's now there
[Music]
is evil here
I'm glad he's on our side
this one's dangerous
but whatever happens
uh
we'll be ready
is it exactly that you bring to this I'm
a planner I make plans you've already
made some plants so the existing plan
fails I make a new plan so you make
plans that fail no he also plays the
loot not relevant
my son sacrificed his life to save me
these powers
are not a gift
but a curse
born out of Rage
[Music]
this Loose Cannon needs to be locked
down
for innocent people start getting hurt
it's been asleep for five thousand years
and find us a cell that can hold them
we'll take care of the breath who's on
the team
I didn't bring a passport you don't need
passports
we're the Justice Society
I got them we're here to negotiate your
peaceful surrender
I'm not peaceful
nor do I Surrender
here we go
I kneel before no one
you didn't come here to seek Justice
you came to exact Revenge
[Music]
fighting against
I never said I was a hero
you believe you are not worthy
but fate does not make mistakes
[Music]
you
can be the destroyer of this world
[Music]
or you can be its savior
[Music]
Sophie I'm Tim for a young man passing
it about music there's no greater place
to be than Mozart's
[Music]
enough what what's this
there's a real magic in this Wars
[Music]
what are you doing back there I have no
idea where I am the young friends bring
back my beloved daughter
you shouldn't take a risk if you're
gonna figure out what it is
[Music]
to rescue you
foreign
library is a portal into Mozart's
beloved Masterpiece yes no
I'm an idiot
I don't deserve these Powers if I'm
being honest like what am I even
contributing
there's already a superhero with a red
suit with a lightning bolt on it
so manly and Batman is so cool and I'm
just me
[Music]
I feel like a fraud it doesn't matter
um anyway a wizard gave me superpowers
but then everybody got super powers
where's everyone going
to fight crime okay
now everyone's kind of like doing their
own thing and I'm the only one trying to
keep it together
[Music]
you understand I'm a pediatrician
right
come on
the fate of the world depends on it
[Music]
children stole the power of all the gods
[Music]
look I might not have as much experience
as you because I'm not super old like
you but I've seen all of the Fast and
Furious movies Lady it's all about
family
family guys that was a signal
[Music]
the world will not survive this
I don't know how we fight powers like
this
I think I know how to fix this dude but
I really don't
really everyone can be worthy let's give
it a chance
now go fight for your family go fight
for the world
I just threw a truck and a dragon I love
my life
[Music]
you ain't driving are you I steer a
little but the reindeer do my sword
this is my fourth year in the center how
about you
I started the whole damn thing
[Music]
decided that you could have one gift
early
what is it that is a direct hotline
Santa Claus himself I can talk to Santa
all right revelers welcome to your worst
Christmas shopping let's go
you have 300 million dollars in your
personal vault
that's what I want for Christmas
[Music]
I don't want any trouble okay someone's
gonna scooch up that chimney
is it not get typical Mall Santa
are you there
you said you were very busy tonight
[Music]
my name is truly like so
are you gonna help us
no my nice list
time for some Seasons beatings
who the hell are you
[ __ ] what if he really is the real no
such thing as Santa
Batman
they're all in my naughty lick naughty
that's naughty
and what do you do to the naughty ones I
give my love for cold
I
believe in you Santa
[Music]
which one of you did that Prancer
so unprofessional
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how did you understand
[Music]
emotion
Al hospitals
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
sorry about the game but we're gonna
have fun tonight
let me guess another it conference I'm
gonna be back in a couple days tops hey
Mom Dad has a work emergency so can you
come pick me up I love it when you call
me Mom let's throw a rager
foreign
what's happening
please don't
[Music]
this is so tight it's some kind of
superhero layer your dad's a superhero
what no my dad can't handle hot wings
I'd have a crazy idea
please don't kill me
oh that's fast
we got him
Whoever has this technology can do
anything
we gotta save my dad's steps before they
destroy the world
torture me
dude that was too long that was way too
long
whoa whoa don't shoot I'm the IT guy I
was alerted to a security breach
why couldn't you tell me about your
secret identity how am I supposed to say
oh by the way some alien power source
chose me to be the guardian of the
planet
it makes you sound crazy right yes
lifetime's over kids prepare for war
[Music]
foreign
so hot you got the winter suit
[Music]
an evil is coming
that threatens Our Kingdom
our freedom
but we have a weapon
they are not prayed for
[Music]
my king the Europeans wish to conquer us
they will not stop into the whole of
Africa is theirs
we must fight back
for our people
is God you're asking me to take them
[Applause]
some things are worth fighting for don't
know
you are called to join the king's God
no Kingdom in all of Africa shares this
privilege to train hard fight harder
they fear no one
and we fear no pain
I offer you a choice fight
or we die
you must kill your teeth
[Music]
we are the homemade
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a crooked federal agent helping
a sex trafficker smuggle women into the
country but he's watching our every move
spend the 30 minutes out we need to move
now
someone tipped them off
place is empty our resources are
compromised sneaking these women in is a
lot easier if you have a border patrol
Chief in your pocket have you lost your
mind you don't just arrest him on a
hunch it was more than a hunch shut up
stay in your lane Sergeant there are
protocols
I am so happy to find you alive they
killed everyone but me and now they want
me dead because I can identify every
last one of them
look the other way
this isn't as good for forgiveness not
permission situation what are you
suggesting we will see our old friend
[Music]
what do you want we need you they need
your help so that these animals can't do
it to another group of girls
what's the plan
if we need anything you can find at the
location date time where and when
they're bringing you have a text thread
with an address to a shipping yard
shipping container ID
Etc will that do I never show off aren't
you okay
let's get to work
I don't have to look the other way I've
got nothing to lose
here I go
Let's Just Breathe
[Music]
I just saw on the calendar that right
now on Earth it's almost Christmas time
we don't have time for trivialities like
Christmas but Peter's so sad about
Gamora being gone
we go to Earth they're a really
wonderful Christmas gift
[Music]
something special you will never forget
what about someone special
we are looking for the legendary Kevin
Bacon we're looking for the legendary
Kevin Bacon your voice is smaller I
think maybe you didn't hear you
you're coming with us as a Christmas
present
[Music]
[Music]
what do we have here yeah here I thought
we were special fellas this here's Bag
Man hang man whatever the hook on the
mission is this
[Music]
everyone here is the best there is who
the hell are they going to get to teach
us
Captain Pete Maverick Mitchell let me be
perfectly blocked you are not my first
choice you were here at the request of
Admiral kazanski AKA Iceman he seems to
think that you have something left to
offer the Navy
what that is I can't imagine
it's all due respect sir I'm not a
teacher
just want to manage the expectations
good morning aviators
this is your captain speaking
and we're off
we're going into combat on a level no
living Pilots ever seen
up there you're dead believe me
my dad believed in you
I'm not gonna make the same mistake
[Music]
someone's not coming back from this
those are your Pilots anything happens
to them
you'll never forgive yourself
no turning back now come on
foreign
[Music]
all right people settle in relax
give me a call
this is
on the line
are you ready I'm always ready we're
expecting your calls talk to Elvis live
on air and tell him about all of your
issues and problems
if it isn't the greatest radio host
okay we got Gary on the line what to say
you Gary
[Applause]
you with this I'm gonna do something
really screwed up tonight are you at
home no does the home belong to someone
you know no it belongs to somebody not
very nice and I'm gonna take out his
whole family
Gary what was that I'm breaking into the
top hey Gary stop wait come on why hurt
his family I mean they're innocent
you're better than that Gary tell me
calmly
where exactly are you
your house
of your life see I created a game and I
think you're gonna love it
[Music]
this can still end well
wanted to end well
I don't want to die here
[Music]
we don't want to die we gotta fight
now I want you to jump
so how about you tell us the truth we're
all listening show yourself you have
slippery Sonoma
honey maybe we should just call it a
night you go ahead I gotta finish these
centerpieces and rearrange the seating
chart
yes
hello Mom now is not the time I just
want to ask is that genetics or is it
like Pilates
we got your gift it's your Something
Borrowed brings you good luck except for
Uncle Greg who ended up decapitated on
that forklift but that's not the knives
fall oh someone just left it in the
bathroom
invited
horn Safari oops you forgot to button
his shirt all the way up
is it time for dinner
you look so much better than the rest of
us I think the left boot is slightly
lower than the right food something
doesn't feel right
[Applause]
here's the plan
spray him in the ice it won't work all
right so many steps
oh
that's white you only have a plan with
once
not once that I wonder if I'd be walking
Hancock Through the Jungle with a life
grenade
oh you got it I got it you got it okay
[Music]
we're gonna fix this
I just grown on me I wanted something
less traditional
nobody with my family
[Music]
[Music]
study your sister
Carol thank you for the cake knife
come on we can do this
we are outgun the only way to catch this
crew is in the ACT keep going New York
turn up the issue I'm dying to give you
the problem
is the opinion of the department that
Shane's night wasn't hunting bank
robbers he'd be robbing banks that might
be rougher on the edges but he's a good
cop This Crew is tight they move like a
team you got a theory or roads lead back
to a businessman because by winner
I hope I'm not uh interrupting what can
I do you for yeah a lot of X Pros I had
a couple of them for a message
do anything about that not to the best
my recollection think real hard
FBI CIA ATF all have open cases on
Winner and two city cops from La walk in
here and they think they're gonna handle
this hey
served in the Marines seems to have some
disciplinary hearing every year I was
thinking but it will try your way in
the night is the most dangerous piece on
the board hello [ __ ] and strike when
you least expect it
awesome are you uh trying to be funny no
I can take you out whenever I want
wherever I want
how can you be at the wrong place at the
right time all the time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
trick or treat mother
[Music]
you're the only person I ever met
alone in the sky
just remember you belong down here with
us too okay
[Music]
the commanding officer called you one of
the best Pilots he's ever seen
[Music]
Aviator
absolutely
[Music]
The Whole World's looking different do
you ever think that you'd be in a
squadron with a colored Aviator
Lieutenant Tom hudner Jesse Brown
it's good to meet you
we're taking a slight detour on the way
home say again
what are you gonna find out about your
wingman improving at 10 000 feet
lieutenant
lieutenant
pull them in a little bit of trouble who
knows we might get a peek at who he
really is
experience came pouring over the 38th
parallel
our guys need help and we're up
we lose they might come Nana doesn't
make it easy
most important thing is this we bring
everyone
home
mistakes gets killed I can't tell you
how many times people have told me to
give up quick
die either
if I did I wouldn't be here
what do you want me to do just be
balling man
the real battle on all the life
being someone that people can count on
show off that was pretty good it's good
you gotta reckon income
foreign
[Music]
you will never have my permission where
is she no come on
you need to help my daughter
load up let's get to it
do you think anyone's following us
we're okay it's Mark open sure I'll make
it right in the end
my men and I are here to bring that boy
in alive so if you're here in some sort
of Vendetta slightly complicate things
I will find him and you're welcome to
every piece of him when I'm done
you hear me
I was in control he was here
I love you your horses carry this sent
to death you wander around this desert
like a bunch of children
a lot of men enforcing your loss on
foreign land
I am tired of it
it's not the way
peace doesn't follow death
[Music]
wait up wait up
what are you doing with all this junk
keeps me busy
another long night of crime and violence
say it's only a matter of time for the
city implodes
I think we're finished here come on Beat
It
I found him
Samaritan
Samaritan died 25 years ago
that's what they say
you think you live across from a
superhero do you have a therapist kid
good
Samaritan is dead
I pick up garbage for a living Fountain
snerd and cleaned up the streets you
mind your business on my mind I
don't
know
are you okay
I'm cool
how strong are you
not as strong as I once was things start
to fall apart when you stop carrying and
I stopped carrying a long time ago
some people it's too late to change the
damage they've done
want to eat that
really
[Music]
the things you buried tend to haunt you
why did you disappear
[Music]
hey old man try this
foreign
hey girl you look just like your mother
[Music]
I promise you I am gonna get her back
genetic power has not been Unleashed
a terrible mistake
the Doomsday Clock might be about out of
time
if our world's gonna survive what
matters is what we do now I can use your
expertise you coming or what
a baby Raptor I made a promise we would
bring her home you made a promise to a
dinosaur yeah why
[Music]
everybody hold on to somebody
that can't be right
what's that biggest carnivore the world
has ever seen
run
see not so bad
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
fella so good to see you I'm sorry it's
under such terrible circumstances yeah
it's fine when your father passed he
left you something very funny is that a
jerk no congratulations you have a boat
right I have a boat
Cheers Cheers I know a place we can go
foreign
[Music]
supposed to be out here
get your hands up
[Music]
wake up the boat's moving four
mechanical locks if we get through all
of those we saw the biometric block we
gotta get off some smoke
somewhere in the middle of the ocean
where's the red button
[Music]
kill her
testing hope for an easy and painless
death power getting fired where did it
go wrong you stole my part
hey look out the window
welcome to my party guys
[Music]
thank you so much for having us this is
my chance to reconnect with the girls
this little bump right here that's you I
still miss her every day
Step At Me
what's that there's something Crossing
up ahead
stay in the car okay just stay in the
car yeah okay what's he saying devil
isn't anything like this
multiple attacks without eating its prey
lives don't do that at least no lion
I've ever seen
go back to the girls
green slow down
we're in his territory now
it's the law of the jungle
it's only law that matters
I've got to get my girls out of here
I need you to trust me right now
I'm coming back
don't you move okay
huh
where'd it go
wow I wonder he lives here
you sure this gift's empty
finger hello
oh what's going on
last night you made the unfortunate
mistake of breaking into my ancestral
home
don't worry this is not an execution
there's the sport in that katak
why did let us go why did they wish us
luck
what's that
it's a fox hunt
[Music]
oh yeah
foreign
[Music]
people are gonna find out about this
about what
staff sergeant Barnes you and the
members of your unit are hereby found
guilty of all the charges brought
against you
what the hell is this all about right
and wrong
Good and Evil
Peoria
breaks my heart when I hear about
missing children people never recover
trying to tell me you want me to kill
people please no
just the minotaurus
can I help you you want to know how
you've been selling underage content for
so long without so much as a warrant for
your arrest
and what's your daughter's name again oh
Betty Betty Betty Hartley
we're not criminals we're sanitation
workers taking out the traps
I don't want anything from this is for
what you do to little kids
I'm FBI special agent Reynolds this is
my partner special agent Kensington we
have a few questions we'd like to ask
you you're just paranoid
Beyond just Luke's watching me I'm
asking the [ __ ] questions all of them
Mr Ambrose do I have your attention
I'd like to thank you for your continued
service large Barnes
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]